in Nevada Steve sisalak has conceded to
Joe Lombardo and the Nevada's governor
oh my God this is a flip the state of
Nevada has just flipped to a republican
Governor from a Democrat it's been four
years in Nevada thank you you live in
Nevada no I I've worked on every
campaign in Nevada that exists I've been
that's how I started my political that
is so how do you really feel about it
what is the best time okay you guys just
like I'm so that guy sucks so bad I am
so happy that Nevada is going red bet on
red guys bet on red do you want to talk
about that I want to talk about this
platform thing because I have an idea so
well let's let's
go black Salt's not looking good it's
it's tightening up so uh in Nevada Adam
laxalt is uh where are we at yeah but it
wasn't I it's uh it's down to he's up by
less than a thousand votes like 700 800
yeah but the votes that are coming in
men are continually skewing Democrat he
was up by a lot more and it's getting
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter so
they're actually I I'm sorry really he's
he may call for a recount or file he
absolutely should 100 same thing with
Carrie like do not stop fight it until
finally they just say get out of the
courtroom that's
especially in Nevada so
so election I did all I I was the last
person to leave I was the last one on
the last plane out of Nevada that didn't
live there right that worked the
election not the RNC people who were
totally corrupt took the money and ran
the next day but
um Nevada is a place where I would
always do a recount always and the thing
is it's like it's not impossible though
because it's like
and I also want to add it Lauren bobert
is uh I'm not gonna say I think Lauren
Roberts is basically one at this point
Lauren bobert's up uh 2 000 about 1 000
just just over 1 000 votes in Colorado's
third with 99 in so she probably won
I mean you would think she's so popular
like to her people well but male and
mail-in voting again again 100 yeah
Democrats get people who don't know
what's going on to vote and their kids
whereas Republicans rely on people to
actively get up and go vote you have
something super difficult and that's why
what you just said actually really
matters and I get in arguments with
people about this all the time where
they're like oh who cares about the
culture I don't want to talk about the
culture War I just want to talk about we
got to talk about like the votes and the
elections today how are you meaning to
create the kind of candidates and the
kind of citizens that want to get up and
vote and vote for the type of candidates
that we need to have if you don't have
the culture element that stuff that's
why it matters so much I'm not saying
one's more important than the other
obviously I'm partial partial to culture
because that's what I do that's you know
but I also do politics so it's like yeah
without like educating your country
you're not gonna get the outcomes that
you want yeah I think you need the
technological element too and I to
piggyback off this conversation about
platform warming and how distribution
the future of you know content
distribution I think about this I think
the the biggest problem one of the
biggest problems with content
distribution is piracy internet piracy
where someone will take your content and
repost it somewhere so if you could
somehow have content so that there's
tags in it or something that every time
it's reposted somewhere else it's still
tracked back to the Creator and you
actually encourage sites to Pirate
contact and sell it and you get a person
you get 98 of the sale the site that
sells it for you gets two percent and
then everyone's going to be selling your
art they're gonna have websites of
people selling tens of thousands of
movies for you that's not dumb that is a
smart way of doing things and that needs
that is something that we need to look
at because it's not that I'm against
I mean look I I grew up not paying for
music I grew up not paying for all the
movies I've seen okay I get it I get it
but the problem is I have investors I
have people that I made a promise to
fiduciary duty
you can't just let this stuff out for
free yeah yeah yeah so if you but I
don't know if you can or if you make
terrible movies that go up on YouTube
that are like you know just what are you
doing made out of crap by myself yeah so
I agree I think that tracking I didn't
say a bad word
I'm doodling pictures tracking the money
is key and and if you could somehow
meditate the content itself like the
movie and then just a lot because piracy
is going to happen we can't stop it
I'm not even I'm just drinking coffee so
that's probably you don't have an excuse
It's the coffee
in that coffee
you try it it's not it's nice it's
caffeine black I don't want it I'm
drawing I'm drawing I won't be able to
sleep I'm drunk Focus gotta drive me
home
yeah but but going back I mean I think
another another big issue that that we
run into is the is the marketing dollars
how do you get you know how do you get
the attention that that you need in
order to drive traffic to whatever
whatever platform you're on so make
something interesting you know well I
mean sure sorry that's the daily wire
speaker no no I mean for conservatives
are you kidding me I think almost all
westerns were made for conservative
that's what I mean but uh but that said
uh you know I just think that surely
they can improve on the genre I mean
definitely I just did one I just wrote
one uh based on a graphic novel that we
just shot in New Mexico with Stephen
Dorff and Cole Hauser starring and Jack
Kilmer uh called dead man's hand it's
based on the same same company that I
gave you that comic book uh rotten tail
uh Source Point press did a graphic
novel uh come a western dead man's hand
that we just uh we just finished
shooting a couple weeks ago actually
have you experienced uh the wokeness I
mean I know earlier there was talk about
the pedophilia but there's also the
darkness in the industry which is also a
big issue you know I mean for me I I
just I I've been on my own path in the
industry since day one really I I
growing up in the industry I was a
graffiti artist before I was an actor
and I kept hanging with all my all my
buddies that I grew up doing graffiti
art with what was your handle hanging
out my first one my first one was Chrome
uh k-r-o-m-e I got caught in 10th Grade
because me and my buddy Dapper were
tagging high schools and Junior highs on
Sunday nights so that everybody would
see our our get-ups on Monday morning it
was a great way to get up but uh and
then I then I switched over to Pike
which is uh which is something that I
still use I still paint were you in L.A
but yeah yeah I grew up in Los Angeles
where did you go to High School uh North
Hollywood High no okay were you there
too Amanda yeah that's one way to get
motivated to go to school yeah the
indoctrination centers the schools oh
man yeah North Hollywood High we had it
back in the 80s we had you know they
used to put remains around the doors
when Once school started in the morning
and lock you in from the outside and we
had barbed wire fences 12 foot high all
the way I was like going to prison every
day for you know five six hours but uh
but it was safe it was predominantly
safe no man people got knifed shot
beaten with pole I saw a guy's shoulder
get collapsed in the quad and we had
full-blown riots and uh it was insane
man it was absolutely insane going to
the in the 80s the gang wars of the 80s
and everything else and uh it was it was
a wild time no doubt dude make a movie
about that I want to see that they did a
couple times I went to school in the 90s
in New York City and again metal
detectors when you walk in craziness oh
you can't even imagine you can't even
just we had we had lap or they still do
I'm sure but we but in the 80s we had
LAPD on campus so you had like principal
assistant to principal Dean assistant
Dean LAPD we had two armed police
officers on campus every day we had a
cop that drove around campus all day
long and and still people got shot and
stabbed and beaten and everything else
Chicago was just walking down the street
people start shooting at each other yeah
oh yeah sometimes it's because the gangs
will be like just kill that person to
prove you're you're yeah that was going
on in the 80s a lot of Fascinations
though they say like this guy they
target you know yeah yeah
um well I guess we could move on topics
but just to cap off this talk about
distribution models you were saying that
marketing money you said that the key is
well that I mean it's it's it's a it's
about driving traffic how do you get how
do you get the eyeballs on on some
content that you're trying to
independently platform without a big
distribution or or major uh film company
behind you are backing you you know so
there is a model to be able to do it but
where is it going to be platformed
that's the thing and how do you get the
money directly so you know are you are
you charging per view on the platform
people go in is it I mean what what is
it it's not there yet it doesn't exist
yet you know so I I am interested in in
the future of platforming but uh you
know of of original content but right
now I have to go with the old model I
mean I'm doing Lifetime movies for
Lifetime channel writing and producing
them and and they're very specific genre
oriented they're sold there they're sold
to tf1 in France they're they're
guaranteed certain sales and all that so
the profit margin is locked in for the
investors and you know and and if one of
them escapes and does better than it's
expected to great but you know the
protection for the investor and and for
everybody else involved creatively is
doing these these specifically genre
films uh you know that that are
guaranteed a certain a certain sale uh
on the front end because a lot of
distribution companies they promise you
a back end that you never get because I
don't want to live like that though see
that's the thing is like I I you're
right you are correct that is the model
that's the the tried and true model that
they taught us at school that's been
going on since forever but I think I
had a win doing it my way absolutely and
I want to keep pushing that envelope
because I I can't like announce what the
idea is for the next thing because then
it won't work right because I just told
everybody what it was but I I I think I
can break the machine and I want to
break the machine because you shouldn't
have to do that you shouldn't have to be
like stuck in this I I know exactly what
you're talking about I just did Cam this
year for the first time yeah and it was
the most like depressing gross
experience of like walking around in
every single country made the same six
movies yeah yeah and like you're like
this is not like the home of Cinema not
to mention like like the obsession with
the Ukraine where you you would think
that like the Ukrainian film had been
like the Cornerstone of European Cinema
for a hundred years
um it was so bananas but uh yeah I I
like I think I'm in a position that I
can
smash that and I I don't disagree with
you what you're describing is the model
and like I just I just don't want to
listen yeah there's a way to break the
mold there's a way to break them well I
think it's easier
because documentaries have a different
lasting they have a different shelf life
than you know when you're marketing I
mean that's the thing is we have a we
have a we have literally half the
companies docs half the company scripted
yeah and like I don't yeah so I've been
in the Grassroots you know putting it
out there and getting it on this
platform and then you find another
platform and then another one and
another I think I fixed the PRL element
yeah I'll tell you what it is after okay
cool I look forward to it um Amazon you
got to get me into that that Mason that
that big thing near my place
I think I think women are not allowed
into yeah
they have George Washington's
um kind of freemasonics
do the Jews run everything or is it the
Masons because the Masons don't let you
in if you're Jewish or so that's not
true or this is uh this is from
Battlestar Galactic so you're telling me
you guys know you guys know what ship
this is this ship do you know what the
ship is no from Battlestar Galactic it
looks like a Kestrel I don't know I
don't know exactly what it is it was a
gift but have any of you seen Lord of
the Flies have any of you have any of
you read or seen no okay this is the
content show you could only talk if
you're holding it I like it oh this is
like a bit of a panic no but I think the
the viewers are starting to complain a
whole lot so how about you hold the
spaceship and you can start talking
about your ideas uh well this I mean you
said Lord of the Flies I just have to
give a shout out to Balthazar Getty then
because that's one of my oh my me and
him were best friends growing up
together that was his first film he did
a great job as you know as the lead in
that uh what this is fantastic you know
I'm distracted I love models I love
Miniatures and stuff so this is just I I
can look at this all day yeah I'm all
about it I know I forgot what we were
talking about oh I don't know should we
talk about something yeah
whatever you guys want well the Mason
conversation is pretty good let's talk
about that what's going on with that
Mason stuff
um well for me I mean I you know I've
been interested in in kind of the
conspiracy theories and stuff like that
my since I was a teenager and uh my when
I found out that you know Freemasons
were the Illuminati and all of this I
was like wait a second my grandfather
and great-grandfather were both Masons
and they sure as hell weren't involved
in any kind of weird racket like that
and uh uh so I got more interested in
the philosophical side of it and reading
you know some some Masonic books and
literature uh and and came to realize
that it's it's it's more of a a
principled philosophical way of thinking
and and and applying uh analogies uh
kind of you could say construction
analogies to life really you know um but
uh so I I got interested in it from that
from from that aspect and then when I
got into my 20s joined a lodge in San
Antonio perfect union Lodge Number 10
around 1997 and did my three primary
degrees uh up through uh you know the
year 2000. yeah I mean uh you know
Freemasonry is is you know a lot of
people call it a secret society uh so
obviously you can't talk about some of
the secrets so what are some of the
secrets yeah no no no you talk about
anything like that the only thing you
can't you can't discuss are just the the
actual initiation rights and and the
dialogue that's used in the initiation
were you able to meet any kind of like
prominent people uh through it there's
been I mean I I I've been to the Grand
Lodge in London a number of times to the
Tea Room there and and there's
definitely some pretty interesting folks
that were hanging around there but uh uh
but uh oh you know overall my my
interested in it is is purely
philosophical and fraternal uh I I
really enjoy traveling the world and
going to other lodges and meeting other
brothers who have the same kind of you
know philosophic mindset and and
curiosity yeah I know like Shaquille
O'Neal is also like a Freemason there's
a lot of other prominent people that are
also Freemason yeah Prince Hall lodges
are are huge they're very very active uh
if I'm I'm pretty sure that I'm correct
that he's in in Prince Hall Lodge which
I have a number of good friends and is
it true that they all go back to the
ideology who was it who invented uh
Freeman's Freemasonry in the United
States was it Albert Albert Pike
introduce Scottish right masonry uh
after uh the Civil War which which I'm
really not into I think that's more of
the the side that sort of is is where
the illuministic side kind of comes from
and to me I think they sponge off the
blue Lodge and by this thing of offering
more light you know so oh there's 33
degrees or 32 degrees with the 33rd
being a bestow degree a bestow degree
but you know they keep offering more
light more degrees more this and there's
just nothing to it it's it's you know
the three primary degrees are the the
most Sublime and that's where you're
going to get your you know your aha
moment what's a degree well that's the
though those are the the three uh the
three initiations that you go through in
blue Lodge uh Entered Apprentice fellow
craft and Master Mason uh and each one
has kind of a different uh a different
series of working tools that they're
based on and also uh you're you're going
kind of through a death and Resurrection
uh um you know uh
a death of Resurrection ideology like
where you're you're letting go of your
old self and opening up to the
possibility of being able to recreate a
whole new uh uh life for yourself as a
new person based on you know from the
ground up meaning you can let go of
everything that you've known from the
past have a clean slate and then
recreate yourself from that point
forward do you do the degrees like
classes do you take classes or is it
some like is it just like work you have
to have a mentor because there's no way
you can do the degree work alone because
you work with somebody else in the in in
the actual initiation it's a q a back
and forth basically do you have to read
a lot of books and then you have to go
through a specific ritual to get to the
next level and then sometimes the ritual
is like a test and sometimes you pass
the test and sometimes you don't yes it
will and that's and that has to do with
the whole q a thing it's you know there
is a performative value to it and and
and what you learn from from what you
memorize and and how you respond and if
you don't have all of this stuff uh um
down to a t that and you won't get
passed on to the next degree you'll have
to repeat that again and again and again
until you get it right and the more that
you read and understand about it then
it's you know the better off you are for
sure can I just ask one thing about it
how does it comport with our belief in
God you have to have a belief in God to
be Mason because the the Bible is is the
light of masonry and and if but if
you're a Muslim and you're you're a mace
and then it would be the Quran or if
you're a Jew and you're a Mason then it
would be the Old Testament versus the in
the inclusion of the New Testament on it
or if you're Hindu then it might be The
Vedas or every single Lodge would
potentially have a different gnosticism
where it's like based in like the
luciferian idea of like absolutely
absolutely not the highest form no
absolutely not okay no no no that that
and uh I mean I I wouldn't say I mean in
having read about the the cathari and
the albigensians and all that I would
never necessarily even say that
gnosticism has that as its fundamental
belief either but uh I I think it has
more to do with the enlightenment of the
of the human soul and the and and the
you know the raising of of oneself to a
higher uh uh experience of Consciousness
I've always found gnosticism makes a lot
of sense in that it just kind of stands
for like the knowledge that you have is
The Enlightenment like the processes the
enlightenment is that Blasphemous to
people of of churches to say that
gnosticism is awesome I mean well most
of the Catholic church because the uh
their Crusades were against the Gnostic
the second Crusades were against the
gnostics and they went and all
throughout southern France and Spain and
murdered them by the tens of thousands
and and uh traditionally there there's
there's a uh through a line of theory
that ties narcissism to the original
teachings of Christ and the original
practicing the practices of of the of
the true Christians uh before the uh the
the Christianity was usurp by the Roman
uh Catholic Church which was previous to
that mithraism they they were it was a a
you know a pagan type belief system
which Pagan is not even a correct term
for it until they got obsessed with the
Jews the Jews and Jerusalem
doesn't Solomon pays a key factor yeah I
was just going to say I literally just
wrote Solomon's Temple I was like
doesn't this go all the way back until
the Knights of Templar or Solomon's
Temple and allegedly the secrets that
they found there and they used that kind
of secrecy to allegedly fight against
the pope right am I correct one of these
because I remember studying this like
years and years and years ago but they
said that he found they found the
treasure they said they said you know
that was the theory is that the Knights
Templar uh either found some old
manuscripts or or actual Treasures or
things like that that they then brought
back to Europe and and and they were
able to you know expand their the you
know the Knights Templar as an order uh
drastically because of this knowledge or
whatever it was that they they got a
hold of which is still a mystery to this
day I've played Assassin's Creed it was
a alien technology wasn't it makes sense
I haven't played Assassin's Creed I'm
familiar with what you're talking I love
the movie
yeah I I think I've seen I I don't know
if I remember the movie but uh in the
first couple of games it was the secret
for like the the progenitors of Earth
aliens and like the Apple was like some
powerful object what's really
fascinating about it is that the symbols
are everywhere the the kind of is it
sacred geometry or is it just because
you look at architecture you look at
corporate logos you look at almost
anything of prominence you look at the
landscape of how Washington DC is built
yes it's all it all comes it's all built
on freemasonic kind of architecture
which is weird also yeah and also
allegedly unlike uh Power Ley lines as
well yes that's true but but really all
of that comes out of the tree of life
the the kabbalistic tree of life and and
the pattern the pattern that it's made
and all of all of the different symbols
come out of that when you when you uh
the the Star of David the deportation of
the Tree of Life
it's the actual connection of all of the
different uh the the connection lines
between the sephardot uh you know so you
have the 10 saffron you have and you
have all of the the connection points
between them and from all of those
connection points the symbolism comes
out of it and that goes into the sacred
geometry of of fractaling and everything
else so it's it's it's uh it's certainly
all of those symbols certainly do come
out of the tree of life but the tree of
life itself comes out of an even more
Sublime symbol and doesn't it take it
down to like how the human body is
constructed absolutely yeah the tree of
life is laid right on top of the human
body you can you can you can you can tie
that in with with the chakraic systems
uh you know it's it's the they're
identical they've just they've just
split them uh on the Tree of Life
they've split they've split several of
them into Dynamic polars but when you
combine them all together it's the same
seven to nine chakras that you generally
find in in a normal system but you can
understand sounds like a lot of stuff
that Ian's talking about you you had
them at fractals and the the aligned
chakras I think I saw Ian's eyes like a
little bit more traditionally like you
have to understand that it's not it's
not that I I uh like disagree with
obviously I know nothing about the
Masons compared to you but like I'm
Jewish right so like I I may not be as
on board with my religious symbolic you
know symbols being
utilized in another
theologies philosophies well I'm Jewish
too so you know but that would I could
say the same thing about you know things
I've seen in Evangelical churches or
things like it's like you know what I
could I could whine about her all day
long I mean in fact you could talk about
the Old Testament the New Testament but
the boys I'm happy it's like we use
Hebrew and we use Hebrew letters and all
of that in in Freeman in Fremont in
Freemasonry when I first saw a Freemason
book I thought it was Hebrew right is it
based off the Kabbalah or is it well
it's involved it's involved it's
involved because I mean and that goes
that goes way back because you also have
to think uh you know that in in the
practicing of of those kind of uh of
that type of magic if the Knights
Templar were involved in in practicing
kabbalistic magic that would be
perceived as witchcraft and and other
types of things
Loyola the founder uh you know the
founder of the illuminata in the 1500s
was practicing Kabbalah and that's who
you know and that's where the Illuminati
comes from in Bavaria by Adam weishau
who was also a Jesuit priest who was
picking back up where ignacio's loyal
Loyola left off back in the 1500s so but
like as a Bavarian Jew
that's how I feel every time you talk
about movies or video games
like all I'm saying is like it just
gives me a little bit of the Heat
like trying to like not have the have
the world come kill you like you know
what I mean like as a Jew just like in
general uh as as does happen like once
every few hundred years or sometimes
more often
um where you're just like yeah
magic and this and that is like I'm just
into God like like the old old testament
old school would you say that you guys
are practicing Magic
uh well everybody is everything is
magical there's there's nothing around
us that isn't Magic every time we're
we're trying to explain something to
somebody as soon as they understand our
communication to them we've performed a
spell because now they're thinking with
our information so there's nothing that
that we're not doing that isn't magical
in essence this table is Magic it wasn't
once a table it was a tree that was then
brought down it was carved changed you
know uh cars how a car is a magic item
you know what I mean it's been it's been
milled from from the ground of taking
ore and molten metal and crushing it and
then shaping it and then putting it
together and then something you put a
chemical into it and start it up and
boom it can drive that's magic I mean
we're surrounded by Magic everybody's
practicing magic I love the metaphor of
casting a spell and when you make words
you spell them yeah the word spell
that's 100 that's where it comes from
what's uh what what makes you want to
become amazing what do you what do you
get from it be it emotional physical or
what um well I mean initially I did it
because my family you know and and but
once I real you know that that was what
my my my attraction was to it but uh but
really what it is is it's it's a system
with which you're you're taught very
it's It's oddly It's oddly complex but
very simple at the same time you know
it's it's it's a it's allegories and uh
and and symbols that once you understand
them they they can they freeze in the
mind and you can access them very easy
it's it's it's a psychology really it's
kind of a psychology so why not publish
it regularly and make it more accessible
it is there's loads of books uh all
about it it's just nobody buys them
nobody's interested and nobody masonry
is open it's just that yeah the only
thing that's closed about masonry is
just the just the initiation process
everything else is wide open all the
books are out there the the the the
Insight there's free Masonic
encyclopedia sets that you can get
there's I mean you name it you can get
it the only thing you can't get is is
access to the actual initiation uh
ceremony unless you join but at the same
time you can even get that information
out there now there's there's books that
where they where they've taken uh you
know our code books and and uh they've
translated them and they've put them out
there to the public it's all accessible
so why is there so many connections
between like
um Masonic imagery and what we've come
to learn about
um Satanic rituals and luciferian stuff
is that just the same sort of thing as
like you know uh what I'm kind of
arguing against which is like you know
frequently like ah the Jews run
everything blah blah blah well is that
the same kind of news or is it yes the
usurption of the symbolism by by
illuminous like the black and white
floors and the two
you're going to have opposing uh
meanings for them by by different groups
so so the see for instance illuminism
Adam weishop they're they're they're
they're they're their sole goal was to
infiltrate and take over Freemasonry and
introduce illuminism into the rights and
practices of Masons so the in in essence
when when you have the Golden Dawn for
instance and and others quasi-masonic
orders that that come out of masonry
they're taking the Masonic symbolism
with them and therefore and then they're
yeah and then they're turning it on its
head so suddenly you're looking at
you're looking at at the Golden Dawn
going oh they're using the same eye and
in the pyramid and they're using the
same this and that and oh that's got to
be Mason City no it's not it's it's not
that's how I got introduced to that
stuff that's why I get heebie-jeebie
about it is because when I was in
college I accidentally went to this
totally bizarre communist college and
ins like I just tried to avoid their
protest classes and I took a Yates class
and it was just Golden Dawn like the
whole time and I was just like I didn't
sign up for Satanism like this
bizarreling
most of the founding fathers were
Freemasons yeah that's the blue Lodge
that's the standard that's a standard
three three degrees
it's you know that's that's the founding
that's that's the foundation that that
all all the other masonic sex are based
on so so even York right which has uh I
believe uh six degrees you know you have
to do the first three to get you know to
go up those you know and same with
Scottish Rite you can't get into
Scottish Rite unless you've already done
the blue Lodge degrees you know so it's
it's really the it's the Bedrock was it
just like a uh but like a way of
teaching and learning and knowing like
if you're a Mason then you know these
things I don't have to worry about you
not understanding 100 the way I view it
you were saying there's a lot of like
mechanical metaphors involve yeah I mean
well for instance the 24 inch gauge
which is used obviously used in
construction for for measuring you know
uh you know you use that to break up
your time uh into three eight hour
segments one for work one for rest one
for recreation uh you use the the uh the
the square encompasses the compass to to
keep your uh desires within due
circumference you use the Square to
Square your actions uh you use the the
level to remain upright you know all of
these you know all these analogies you
apply to the self and you and you are
the Mason and the edifice that you're
building is in the mind this gets into
Solomon's Temple is that there that in
in Freemasonry there's a there's a
strong belief that the that the first
temple was never built that it was only
built in his imagination and that it was
never actually built in physical reality
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time